[Laughter]
foreign
[Laughter]
no seriously it just I forgot to scroll
and it wouldn't go up to the thing like
if you use OBS you know I'm talking
about you have all the little scenes
over here Zach says uh well hey
everybody
happy Friday uh Zach says somehow I just
managed to cut myself while pulling a
loose string uh yeah that sounds like
some [ __ ] I would do
you know just cut himself on a string I
guess huh wait did you cut yourself on
the string or in the course of pulling
on the loose string you cut yourself on
something else uh we want to hear the
story we want to hear the story behind
this
so Jenny and I are gonna do the uh
the little show today gonna keep you uh
occupy keep you company uh get you ready
for the weekend
it's uh Friday night you're gonna wind
down and then we're gonna go out to the
club
yeah I'm gonna go to mannequins
but happily I at least know that we're
going this time so I already kind of did
my makeup and hair so all I have to do
is change clothes so we don't have to
like brush necessarily but probably a
better idea if we don't drink a [ __ ]
done
because I feel like last Friday we
didn't drink a [ __ ] ton on the show well
at least like no more than usual but
then like we drank an alarming amount
like when we went out you know but I
think we danced a lot so it didn't
really seem I didn't really seem like I
got that that drunk you know what I mean
you know what I mean yeah
you are right okay
let's do everything to say to it oh all
right
uh Zach says with the string itself
while pulling it I didn't even know that
was possible
well you know I mean it could be
depending on what kind of string it is
they could cut yourself sure I've cut
myself with thread before
uh Danny Rowling said Tom which is the
better out of the two Marine Raider or
Army Ranger
depends on what you're looking for
they're both good units Marine Raiders
are kind of like
Naval SWAT teams they're real good at
like uh boarding ships that's all close
combat stuff it's it's just pretty much
like SWAT team type stuff Army Rangers
are general purpose they're
elite elite Airborne Infantry
uh they're more about being in larger
numbers fighting
more conventional style units but doing
a really [ __ ] difficult mission that
has to be done if the ambition isn't
done then that whole offensive or
something is going to fail
um so there has to be more Rangers but
they're when they're when they're done
right and they're not being done right
now okay
[ __ ] just look at [ __ ] Terence
pops show
these [ __ ] Airborne Rangers Army
Special Forces was in like 30 something
years and retired he went to they put
him through the [ __ ] ringer and uh
Rangers and SF are not what they used to
be uh the the standards since the 80s
and the 90s have dropped a lot
um but
Army Rangers back in the day were
badass infantry hand-picked infantry
basically uh they they were special op
they were it was Special Operations but
it's Special Operations where you need
thousands of guys like a big enough
Force to get something done
um
compared to Marine Raiders now those
guys that are in those Marine Raider
units [ __ ] come from other units a
lot of them have been to Ranger school
uh army trains a lot of those guys so
the
all your real hardcore uh uh [ __ ]
Marine individuals then they go into
like [ __ ] Marine recon units and
[ __ ] Raider units they're trained in
Army schools the Navy doesn't have those
schools and and Marines isn't big enough
to run those schools they're little unit
it's just a core you know a couple
divisions three divisions I think
it's just different
when it comes to like Rambo [ __ ] living
out in the field for [ __ ] months and
months and [ __ ] people up and Ambush
counter ambush
[ __ ] fortified making defensive
fortifications
[ __ ] infiltrating in an area on foot
or Airborne [ __ ] [ __ ] Vietnam style
stuff or they are dense offensive style
stuff or D-Day type [ __ ]
well hi you know like [ __ ] what they
did on D-Day was [ __ ] fantastic but
you want Rangers for that there's more
of them they are mean the the a ranger
doesn't have to be anything but 100
dedicated fall on his sword type
[ __ ] physical endurance no sleep
no food can [ __ ] be outside for
months in [ __ ] horrible weather and
they just do the mission no matter what
they literally want dudes that will walk
themselves to death they want dudes that
will starve themselves to death they
want dudes that will [ __ ] keep stay
awake for weeks on end
psychos
it's a warrior cult
the highest Echelon of the warrior
called the Army Rangers they're not
particularly skilled they're just
[ __ ] badasses but it's more about
endurance they can just endure [ __ ]
tremendous hardship
uh other than that they're just Infantry
but they got a good chain of command
that's [ __ ] been been vetted and
they're put on missions that are
important
very different Mission than Special
Forces and Raiders and stuff it's its
own thing
but out of the two
in general purpose good a good Ranger
probably
for just general purpose like in a
Walking Dead [ __ ] end of the world
situation Army Raider but no I wouldn't
laugh at Marine Raiders either it's just
it's just because the the end on the
individual level they're real similar
they're real similar on an individual
level
Dave is here hello you two just closing
up my store hey you we're probably going
to mannequins later actually we'll
probably definitely going we're going
we're definitely on yeah I already did
my hair and my makeup and everything
like that she's still like look at her
what's up she's laying on her back she's
so crazy
um Oracle said uh I have some sad news
to share last Saturday our cat smoke
lost his fight with end stage renal
disease I'm still really sorry that's
awful how old was the cat that makes me
really really sad
yeah Oracle said yeah we've known him
since he was about two weeks old his
mama was rescued by a friend she was
going to get fixed when he realized uh
she was pregnant he was 16 years old
so
that's so sad
man that's it that bombs me out that
bums me out
um let's see and Zach is talking about
Cuts I still think the most painful Cuts
I ever had was on the cover of a math
book in fifth grade that was made with
that real thin cardboard material I
remember books made with that I remember
that
I can't really remember like and
any real painful Cuts I had one one that
I had one time when I was like
shaving my legs
and the razor like cut I didn't realize
at the time but it like cut sideways
like right across where
um the front of my leg like went into my
foot and I didn't realize that I'd cut
it at the time but then all of a sudden
like blood started gushing out and I
couldn't get it to stop and I started to
panic so you know and I kind of got a
little bit faint too oh also one time at
work back in the old days uh when
graphic designers had to like do paste
up still because that's how [ __ ] old
I am
um where you know they print out like
the lines of copy because I worked for a
newspaper and you had to like you know
paste all the [ __ ] and like want it
through run it through the wax machine
and everything so you had to like cut
all these strips of ads and
you know classified ads and stuff like
that out with a uh exacto knife and I
actually cut off the tip of my finger
with an exacto knife uh and I kind of
obviously well I almost had to go to the
bathroom and I was just kind of like I
was like oh well [ __ ] look what I did
and um I kind of went in the bathroom
that I was like I thought I was gonna
faint for a second but I was all right
and then like I just taped it back on
and eventually I grew back so you know
it bled a lot though it was like pretty
alarming it was pretty alarming
um Rob says Tom I just hooked up my
surround sound and subwoofer and put on
Rambo yeah in 2008 holy [ __ ] first time
seeing it is that the one with all with
all the gore the 2008 I think he's
talking about Fight Continues oh okay
Rambo Fight Continues because he said
Rambo that there's five of them yeah it
was like which which ramble was that I'm
always just I don't even remember what
that one is called like Rambo the Gory
one it's called the Fight Continues okay
the Gory one I don't know I think it's
the best one
I mean from a horror movie standpoint it
definitely is although I want to see the
director's cut of the [ __ ] last of
last blood
uh the one where he's fighting the
cartels there's evidently deleted scenes
I remember seeing we saw that one in the
theater that was pretty good too but
yeah it was soft though it wasn't as fun
as the previous one but there's supposed
to be a bunch of deleted [ __ ] so I think
I have it on Blu-ray I'm not sure
no I don't think I had yeah I think I
have it I would think I might have it
yeah Oracle said um you know the car
that died and said we still have his
Litter Mate and the litter mate's been
grieving all week I gave him the towel
with smoke scent on it and that towel
has become his wooby oh that's so sad
God damn it
I mean that's I don't know it makes me
so sad
the Rambler we go to boat man told to
stay on the boat by the
I can't read the SAS Soldier but and
that's the rainbow where he was the boat
man and told him to stay on the boat
yeah that's the fight continue yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then a baby's like I don't
want to get involved in this [ __ ]
and then he's like okay I'm gonna get
involved in this [ __ ] that's where
he hooked he was and I'll really get
involved in all the [ __ ] because I'm
gonna kill everybody that's when he was
living in Vietnam or living in uh
he was over there he wasn't living in
Vietnam I don't think was he was living
in uh uh
for Cambodia Myanmar yeah he was living
in Myanmar or something he hooked up
with you remember
yeah Myanmar he hooked up with that uh I
don't know why I remembered that band of
[ __ ] hired guns that were supposed to
help that those Christian missions
rescue those Christian missionaries yeah
that's right yeah all I remember was his
head's blowing off and I was like oh
that's blowing up that's one of the best
Rambo movies
because you know [ __ ] you know I love
that kind of stuff it's Stallone's face
was [ __ ] up for that movie man I guess
he was on H oh it's Burma okay so Burma
so I was wrong yeah but he he was living
in Burma but he goes in Myanmar I think
wasn't it I think it was I don't know I
just pulled that out my ass I could be
totally wrong I think it was I mean I
know it's a real place I'm just yeah I
pulled it out my ass like I don't
remember if the movie took place there
yeah it was just the first thing that
occurred to me and then uh [ __ ] what I
was gonna say he was gonna uh
yeah I was going to say the [ __ ]
Sylvester Stallone's face was all [ __ ]
up for that one he looks a lot better
now I guess he got it fixed but he was
messing with that I think I think human
growth hormone I think I would did yeah
he probably had to go to a plastic
surgeon they had to put there put their
foot on the back of his head and pull
yeah
they did a good job on him that's just
what I always imagined like when
somebody goes and gets it I have to do a
good job on him his wife is like 30. so
he has to [ __ ] you know do it he has
to look good
I think he's what that's his fifth wife
I think I don't know I don't know why
his new one I think he was like she was
like 25 when he married her
I wonder if his daughters were just kind
of like we're dead no no dude's been
doing it for thousands of years well I
know that yeah I'm just saying it's
still weird I would think it was weird
like if you know if my dad had like
hooked up with a woman that was my age
or younger or younger I mean I'd be like
creepy you know yeah I would just think
that was Warlords and [ __ ] [ __ ]
important dudes have been doing that for
thousands years have whole harems a lot
of times they keep them all all at the
same time they don't fire the old wives
they just kind of retire them you know
[ __ ] give them a bonus you get a
retirement bonus so you got the senior
wives and all the junior wives but here
they're kind of forced to cut them loose
but I I guess that you know which I
don't know how that happened in in a
Christian setting because originally
Christianity was like that a lot of
people don't realize that but
there were you know early Christians
were a lot more like Mormons they just
married
successive wives one after the other and
then most people didn't get married they
just lived together
they just said they were married that's
another thing yeah it's not like you
could check back you couldn't check back
then
it's like you couldn't look it up on the
internet check out the like the legal
records and nothing and I think it was
only uh three or four hundred years ago
where they made people get married
because they wanted that money
that uh over in Europe the church said
now we're gonna have to charge these
peasants for getting married
before they just if you lived together
then you were married yeah and everyone
is like well yeah I kind of feel like
The Peasants largely where they were
just kind of like yeah whatever people
just like shacked up together and
everything yeah they'd have a ceremony
in the in the bar they just go to the
[ __ ] Pub we're married now yeah and
then they get loaded
and they already had two kids that kind
of [ __ ] right
the church said no no we need that money
yeah cha-ching yeah we want to squeeze
every penny yeah how many people that
don't have anything right only rich
people got married I was telling sub
that he lives up to Saudi Arabia really
only rich people got married
traditionally in the West in the western
civilization then it was rich people and
it was an exchange of money even dowries
and [ __ ] joining empires together
they got what I meant they got married
in a church
only rich people got married in churches
yeah no yeah she's trying to go go in
that other screen
yeah what's
with her
right okay
you gonna talk about that all day long
let's talk about the fans talking about
the fans she just can't go yeah she's
telling us about it which is like so
funny she's like that fan what is what
is up with that like could you do you
guys know about that that's on yeah she
jumped up on my other desk and she's
like staring at it
you're like she's hysterical she's
hysterical
um
yeah Rob said damn he just disemboweled
someone yeah it's you know oh is he
watching it now yeah it hits a lot yeah
but like I said it's the most straight
up like a horror movie I think it's the
best one I think it is too well I mean
other than the first one which is
obviously like objectively like that's
the best movie but I kind of feel like
that one is the most entertaining just
because it's so like over the top gory
yeah well that was that was Rambo coming
back after all this time yeah
so they had to like they had to [ __ ]
Pokey get down oh my God what are you
doing yeah that's it that's a wrap
you're in trouble okay good girl
Dave says here I am driving hearing a
meow meow and it's Pokey yeah yeah she's
she's very upset about the ceiling fan
and she's always keeps like telling us
about it like oh my God oh my God you
guys oh my God oh my God it was like she
just jumped up on my other desk over
there it must be the blades must be in
Balance because it wobbles slightly and
then I think she's afraid it's gonna
fall yeah it's upsetting her yeah I mean
it's funny
Zach says I love when Jenny's in her
crazy old cat lady makes guest
appearances yeah I'm always a crazy old
guy lady that's okay
you know she's like a little person
she's like our little fuzzy daughter so
we talked to her like she's a little
person she acts like a little person she
acts like a little brat a lot of the
times but you know she's still
delightful
no no now she's attacking my other one
oh no she runs away getting old she
likes to eat the damn tape that so it
covers up the camera yeah
that's her that's one of her favorite
things it's like because he has that
little piece of tape that he puts over
and it's like you actually attacked the
teeth when daddy's not looking
she'll go over there and be like I can
try to like chew it off of off of there
and it's funny because I think I said
this before but you had an old one of
those like an old tablet and he put like
little pieces of tape like all over it
like for her to play with like a toy and
she wouldn't do it she's like nope I
don't want that one I want yours like
and she wouldn't play with the one that
didn't work anymore yeah she just wanted
the one that Daddy was was using which I
thought was really funny even though the
other one had like tape all over it so
you'd think she would like be having fun
but you know uh let's see oh here's one
thing we were talking about this the
other night and we wanted to kind of
like run okay I know stop talking
laughs
yeah
it's funny because she's like she has
meows but it's like all these different
like inflections you know what I mean
she she can talk a little bit but she
does talk yeah I mean she has that like
little tone of voice like different
what'd she say that time what do you
want me to do about it
she wants me to stop it stop it let me
stop it I cannot stop it come here
stop stop it
grafter says uh some people call the
tape over the camera masturbation guard
see Slash thread said one of the classic
horror games I remember is Castlevania
yeah because that could start a horror
games I wish I had more time to like get
into those because some of them look
super fun I remember playing Castlevania
a long time ago like back on the [ __ ]
Nintendo but
Uh Kevin says wow Mr Clean you must not
have been here for a while I guess
because he's you've been you've been had
your hair like that for lack of hair
like that for a long time right
and Friday the 13th for NES is a classic
I don't I don't think I ever got to play
that one unfortunately
yes oh okay so something that we were
talking about the just idea we were
throwing around and we've kind of talked
about this before but we've never got
around to it but we were kind of
thinking about
um doing kind of more like field
stuff you know what I mean like going
out and doing
um like I don't know like going around
close places around here that are like
haunted or like where the scene of a
crime or something like that and like
kind of go like and do like location
I don't know if we do necessarily live
streams because I don't know if I really
have
um anything like the capacity for doing
that but we could do like some reflected
uh or uh recorded stuff I guess
but I don't know like we were talking
about that and
as maybe something we would start doing
but it would be it would need like a lot
of planning and we probably only do it
like once or twice a month right are you
talking about the thing we were talking
about yeah yeah yeah yeah that's why I
kind of wanted to get your input in on
this but
like about because it was kind of your
idea right I mean we've talked about it
before yeah we I think I think it's I
think it might be a good idea if we do
some uh material that is not in studio
that's outside
maybe some kind of Investigation where
maybe we'll do a trip
somewhere like I don't know my murder
mystery murder you know like the scene
of some kind of crime will [ __ ] tour
you through it or
um or like some place that's supposed to
be haunted if you're supposed to be
haunted something like some [ __ ] like
that or something like that we'd have to
come up with
decent ideas so it's almost kind of like
Urban exploration Maybe
yeah I was thinking I mean because there
are some places around here like I said
there's Cassadaga there's Saint
Augustine there's like there's stuff
around here that's like supposed to be
there's some sites in Orlando too I
think but I don't know like how
accessible they are or like on uh we
could do what because I think Dan Bell
did this for a while too where he just
had um he just did like random Nautica
yeah you know what I mean ran a Nautica
yeah what's a ran a Nautica it's that
app
I've never even heard of it yeah it's
like it's an app say it again Rando
Nautica Rando Nautica yeah it's an app
that on your phone and basically what
you do is you're supposed to go in there
and you're kind of like
supposed to like uh you know give them
your location how far of a range you
want
and then you're supposed to like
manifest like what you want to happen
like think about it and then it gives
you a random location that you're
supposed to go to so it's supposed to
have like Adventures you know what I
mean so yeah Dan bell used to do he I
don't know if he does it anymore because
he does like uh Saturday Night Live
streams where he like drives around
Baltimore and like goes to abandoned
places and stuff but for a while he was
doing random Nautica and he like came up
with some weird [ __ ] like he'd go to
some place being like Oh we want to go
someplace spooky and then he'd go like
they'd end up in this like really really
creepy [ __ ] place with like [ __ ] a
broken doll in the yard and [ __ ] like
that it was like it was pretty fun so I
was like yeah we could maybe do that or
like I said if we had time to plan
um
you know
because there's a lot of stuff like
within you know like an hour or two of
here that we could probably go to
I was even looking in Orlando I think
there's a place in Orlando where there's
like some supposed to be like some park
that's haunted or some [ __ ] like that
Ascent bees nest
a cash app
money today he says it didn't it didn't
arrive how long does it take do you guys
know how long it takes for them
first time I sent him some money he said
he got it instantly now he's saying he
didn't get it
should be instant huh
well I don't know it depends well
because sometimes remember how I always
had to send stuff yeah and then like
sometimes they would get it right away
and sometimes not yeah right so if you
listen I'm not sending you no more money
dude if if uh and I sent him the
photographs of the proof that I sent it
and uh if he wants to cry like a [ __ ]
bee's nest [ __ ] contact Cash app
don't call me about it
any problems with cash app not me I
should I show you the receipt
all right if you need money that bad go
out there and suck some dick you'll get
some money
man like you [ __ ] literally sitting
on a gold mine
telling his booty like that Kevin says
how was your Halloween what did you do
uh we dressed up we went to um the
mannequins Halloween party on Saturday
night
and then Monday night we'd dress up in
our costumes I was Medusa by the way and
um we did a live stream and then we gave
out candy like for the rest of the night
and that was pretty much it uh also
asking about hurricane damage no we
didn't get any we didn't get any now the
bad hurricane that we had before because
it seems like you haven't been here in a
while the bad hurricane that we got
before uh the power was out for a while
but it wasn't out that long and we
didn't really have like any damage and
the one that just hit the other day
wasn't even a hurricane it was like a
tropical storm so that just kept me
awake with the wind blowing but that's
about it we didn't even lose power or
nothing Danny Rowling said the home of
the lady in Florida that spontaneously
combusted would be cool to see I
remember that yeah we were talking about
Coral Castle
which I mean I think that's like a four
hour drive maybe farther but it's still
in the state though because in that down
in the South what Coral Castle
yeah it's a couple hours from here isn't
that like in Fort Lauderdale or
somewhere like that I can't even
remember and that's like that's like
four hours from here about it used to be
out in the middle of nowhere now it's
like downtown so well that's kind of
happening
I mean like I said
um Cassadaga is
maybe an hour from here uh and that has
like the that thing like the Devil's
Chair like in that cemetery and that's
like all those psychics and stuff like
I've only been there one time
maybe well no maybe twice but it's been
a long time since I've been there and
like I said you know St Augustine I've
been there lots of times there's all
kind of haunted [ __ ] there so and
there's also all kind of other cool [ __ ]
there too like a lot of cool cemeteries
and whatnot so I don't know I kind of
feel like
that might be a fun thing to do and
everybody kind of says yeah Do It um I'd
love to see that yeah it might be a what
maybe we should like start doing in the
new year or because that's only a couple
months away and then that would kind of
give me time to like plan some stuff out
and like make sure we had the right
equipment and
figure out like how we were going to do
it like I said we might not live stream
it because I don't know if we have
anything that has that capacity like to
live stream for a long time
uh you know
but we could maybe like record some [ __ ]
and then I could come back and like edit
it together so that might be yeah Camp
guy said Savannah yeah that might be
cool too like Savannah's a cool place
that's probably
I want to say that's maybe six hours
maybe farther
well I remember that one time when I
still lived in Daytona which is a little
which is north of here I drove to
Atlanta and that was six hours
but I don't know
but Savannah is like over on the coast
though isn't it so I'm not really sure
like how long that would take yeah now
bees nest comes back and [ __ ] shows
me the receipt where he received the
twenty dollars saying see I didn't get
it and it says right there on the
receipt that I sent in the 20 learn how
to use [ __ ] technology you [ __ ]
let out you you got it send it to your
[ __ ] bank
[Laughter]
I don't know why you guys don't know how
to use these things
he's a [ __ ]
you didn't know how to use it either
you'd ask me yeah but once you kind of
use it a few times it's easy yeah it's
easy it's easy yeah
yeah Kevin said it uh talking about
Rando Nautica it sounds like a haunted
version of Geocaching yeah it is kind of
like that because so many people use it
that um it kind of like has little
little hubs and like little points of
like where interesting [ __ ] is so it
doesn't have to be haunted like the
whole thing of it is that you're
supposed to oh Jesus Christ you're gonna
like knock that over one of these days
um you're supposed to because you don't
have to like think you don't you know
you don't have to manifest like
something scary it's just that you know
why wouldn't you because that would
obviously be the most fun thing
um but you can manifest anything you
want you know what I mean like I want to
find something happy or want to find
something peaceful or blah blah you can
do whatever you want but like I said I
don't know why you do anything like
other than scary because that seems like
the most fun thing but you know I'm not
you so I'm not judging
Zach says I think I read recently Dan
Bell is making a movie I bet it'll be
awesome
he did
um what's that one documentary that he
made but I think the documentary that he
made um well I mean he's made a lot but
I mean the main one that he'd been
working on I think he made it about
those people
it was it was in Florida actually like
he made it about those people that like
lived in that okay
that lived in that Motel I can't
remember what their names are he put it
on YouTube it's on there I haven't
watched it yet though
but I mean his one of my favorite things
that he ever posted and I think it's
still on YouTube he has like two
channels he has one that's called this
is Dan Bell one that's called film it
um
and he kind of puts different things on
both of them
but one of my favorite things that he
did and I've watched it a couple of
times because his voice is really
relaxing is
um he drove he was talking about driving
um like through the Everglades and so he
tells like all these really creepy
stories about
driving through the Everglades and
there's like some he's mostly like dude
like he's just talking and he's showing
like maps of where he was driving and
like telling stories about it but it's
like for some reason I just I really
like that because I think guess he lived
in Florida for a while like I said he's
from Baltimore but
I don't know I kind of like
I kind of liked the idea and we've like
I said we've been throwing it around for
a while we just never really got around
to doing it but it would be neat to kind
of like get you know out of the studio
like from time to time and like do
something that's out
you know out in the wild somewhere but
I'd have to like look around and see if
there was anything worth
uh I don't know worth covering like when
we get there
and I'm trying to and I'm kind of
thinking maybe we'll do like you know a
place where like something creepy
happened or like haunted it's supposed
to be haunted or I don't know some [ __ ]
like that
I don't really want to go like
trespassing on people's [ __ ] or nothing
like that but
you know I just think that would be kind
of like a fun to do
grantor said Detroit is urban
exploration heaven with 80 000 abandoned
buildings yeah I've heard uh just watch
out for the feral Rottweilers and be
sure to step over the corpses of dead
addicts yeah
uh let's see
yeah Kevin said Bachelor's Grove
Cemetery uh Midlothian Midlothian I
think we talked about that on one of our
shows a long time ago what's the matter
with you baby
she keeps yelling
what's the matter I know the fan I know
you don't like it
I know you don't like it uh Zach says
New Orleans yeah I mean that's a bit of
a drive too
how long is it to drive to how long
would it be to drive okay New Orleans
would be about eight hours probably
about an eight hour drive from here and
it's it's an easy drive but it's long
what is it I-75 or I forgot the name of
it you only have to do one well not I4
or would it be or wouldn't it be oh you
go up by four all the way and then you
hit I think it's I 45 or something
and turn left and then that goes right
to New Orleans I think I-95 because I-95
is the one that goes north south
95 then yeah yeah I-4 is only in Florida
yeah but it goes up there
no I-4 just goes east to west from
Daytona to Tampa okay I thought it went
all the way up to 90. no no no okay no
I-95 is probably the one you're thinking
of that's the one that goes all the way
from Key West all the way up to [ __ ]
main is I-95
um let's see
yeah they're coming up with like places
to
to go to like I said it's probably if we
started out doing it we would start out
um places that were like local you know
what I mean that we could just like
drive to like in a day and that we
didn't have to like stay overnight
because like I said I can't afford that
[ __ ] but you know so places around
Orlando around like I said St Augustine
Cassadaga like that kind of places
because we can get there like in a brief
amount of time
but it would have to be something like
where we do a show at a location yeah
where that [ __ ] happened
and maybe find maybe maybe find people
that well a lot of the shit's gonna be
really old there won't be any Witnesses
but
you know we'll see yeah I go out where
they [ __ ] saw the Florida Skunk Ape
and then we'll do a skunk ape show up
yeah we should probably do that kind of
shape show yeah
because then it well skunk ape I don't
even know I haven't I think we talked
about second cape on one of them skunky
well I know that but I mean they got
people that swore that there is but I
know but it's like um I think we did a
show or we talked we didn't do a whole
show about skunk ape but we I think we
talked about it on um one of our Cryptid
shows yeah and I'm not real sure like
how widespread
skunk ape sightings are in Florida you
know yeah it's not just an everyday
couple only a couple times there's a
problem with Cryptid sightings in North
America okay
there would have to be a breeding
population of them it'd be enough of
them to where they could [ __ ] keep
the breeding population going
which means in the in in North America
you couldn't hide that
just look at the map of North America
it's real hard except out in the desert
to go further than [ __ ] 20 and 30
miles and not hit a road roads are just
everywhere
so those things would be crossing the
roads all the time if there's a lot of
them you see them holy [ __ ] it's this
gun Cape yeah you'd see them well hell
man I've even seen alligators walking
across the street yeah like in a regular
yeah area and then there'd have to be
and then they would make an ecological
impact that's another thing
they'd be eating food you'd notice it
and something like a skunky
that's [ __ ] PR that would be a prime
creature to [ __ ] raid garbage cans so
you'd see them in garbage cans fighting
with the bears fighting with the Bears
to get the to get the garbage hey bear
this is my [ __ ] you're right I have
opposable thumbs right
now some people would say Well they're
intelligent they're you know if they
were intelligent they'd head towards man
is what they would do
because all the intelligent creatures
head towards human habitation well
because it's easy where the food is
that's where the food is it's like look
at all the [ __ ] they throw away it's
like we can just like live high on the
hog man look at like raccoons and stuff
and they're like all we got to do is
come up to your door and be cute and put
our little or a tiny little human-like
hands out and yeah you'll give us food
yeah raccoons will come up to a house if
you feed them once they keep coming back
and they beg and they just I'm cute give
me some food and they'll come into your
house they'll tear your house up and I'm
like oh and then they'll bring all their
friends you just go on YouTube
you'll see guys who feed the raccoon
trick-or-treating and he'll have
60 raccoons in his house and he can pet
them all oh you know because they're
pretty they know when they're being fed
and they make friends easily not gonna
bite the hand of feet yeah well like I
said that's an easy life for them yeah
you know that they just like go around
and I told you like where I used to work
in the newspaper like there was a little
family of raccoons that lived in the
parking lot and like because people out
it was a big huge parking lot because it
was a big newspaper but um you know
people would come out there at night and
feed them like give them Pizza crusts
and like leftovers and stuff like that
so yeah they would if they saw a person
coming out to the car at night they'd be
like yeah with their little hands out
like hey you got something yeah yeah
it was super cute they're little
American monkeys they're close to like a
monkey and a bear kind of cross between
thing you know they beg put their hands
up and try to be cute and they have
those like cute little people hands it's
like it's a it's a little unsettling but
it's also like and uh we used to think
they were kind of fierce you know but
now that you have YouTube you can see
what other people have done with them
they're friendly
friendly and social
um as friendly as a dog
and Mark I would say probably more
intelligent than a dog
maybe it's a different kind of
intelligence but
they're they're pretty slick
Beijing used to really like the raccoons
that hung out by our old place yeah we
thought used to think that raccoons
might kill cats and stuff and now they
get along great raccoons love cats and
cats like raccoons it's like interracial
[ __ ]
[ __ ] well at least our cat really
likes raccoon she was like oh these are
so cute and they're like loving on her
yeah fluffy cat
like four raccoons they're looking at
her like look at this thing
and Beijing would never tolerate another
cat but she liked those raccoons yeah
her and Pookie even still able to get
along I mean they get along they
tolerate each other but yeah they're
still if Beijing tries to come upstairs
Pookie is like absolutely not having it
she's like get out of here this is my
yeah it's funny
the Beijing ran into a a raccoon at the
old house remember she ran up to it was
standing next to it yeah go and look at
this thing look at this yeah yeah it's a
raccoon he's like what the [ __ ] is this
thing look at it she was excited she's
like it's like a kitty but not yeah yeah
I can't but no
but no there's definitely a cute Factor
yeah animals do judge each other on
looks because they do cats do not like
possums there's like that thing's ugly
they'll follow it and hissing at it and
want to touch it but they're afraid to
touch it because they think it's dirty
and then the poor possums are like
absolutely
I can't help them yeah yeah no they
don't like possums they don't attack
them but they they
they're fixated by the ugliness of a
[ __ ] possum and they're trying to
they raise the alarm look at that thing
look at that thing look at it
help somebody else yeah so
apples are just
across the board like humans they judge
you on how they look they're superficial
[ __ ]
I would imagine too that probably smell
has a like a much larger uh is a much
larger Factor than yeah than for humans
yeah but it looks too well now I'm not
saying that I'm just saying that
probably how they smell is probably
mammals know that reptiles don't look
safe
even Turtles they're like that's bad you
know they don't like that
and it's funny but I've seen them
and they see [ __ ] snakes and they
just know hell no you know they totally
refuse that
there somebody uh some people are um
recommending like places that we go camp
guy says Ted Bundy areas and that dude
that killed those college students in
Tallahassee are you talking about um
that Siri look at Danny rolling because
that was in Tallahassee that was
Gainesville
but it's
Tallahassee is wait Tallahassee is
Florida State and Gainesville is
University now murder Hornet shows up
Dad's talking bad about you on the show
bro I was telling you if you needed that
money so bad you didn't go out there and
start sucking some dick and a
[ __ ] like you sitting on a damn
gold mine with a tight ass of yours and
also I think he called out there and
make some goddamn money if you need that
much money just you know you're not
pretty but you're skilled okay
not a deal ask Zach Zach can tell you
all about it
John Gore said problem is they're rabies
prone I guess raccoons no yeah well yeah
yeah they also carry some kind of damn
kidney thing
that'll [ __ ] up your kidneys but they're
nowhere near as dirty as people think
they are those wild animals are actually
pretty they're pretty they're clean well
they can't be that dirty otherwise they
get infections and stuff um
[ __ ] possums can get kind of dirty
because they're just slow and they just
get in the garbage a lot
um
but it doesn't matter because they don't
live long anyway I think a possum only
lives two or three three years I think
is how long they live but there are some
people that have kept them as pets and
they'll they make a good pet when you
look at it you wouldn't think they'd
make a good pet but evidently they're
real friendly slow and as long as you're
feeding them they're real happy and
affectionate they're so cute and chubby
yeah but those are like you can't take a
wild one and do that they'll get little
pups and [ __ ] raise them from hand
and they make a good
house pet I think they can even be
litter box trained
yeah I don't know see I don't see why
not and you wash them you know and keep
them clean and they kind of groom
themselves and they they're evidently
like real affectionate
you know one that's been raised by hand
you know I've you know I've had a you
had a squirrel or a raccoon what was it
a squirrel a squirrel okay we found it
when it was a baby it fell out of its
nest yeah its eyes were still closed my
Dad's friend had a raccoon he didn't he
only lived a couple years though yeah
uh my Dad's friend had a raccoon and but
the raccoon was allowed to come and go
and it was it would go a lot and then
come back and sleep in the house and it
was uh
you can't keep one in the house they'll
tear the [ __ ] house up okay so you
have to you have to give them the option
to leave
uh wait a minute I saw something I
wanted to answer oh Zach says I love
videos of cats and dogs that are playing
like BFFs
I I like any kind of like inner species
like
video like what was that one that was
like the cat and the owl that were
friends or like a cat maybe it was a cat
and a crow I think there was two
different ones Ben says it's not gay if
it's for pay
yeah well that's what they said keep
that in mind [ __ ] Kevin said quit
pimping out your friend LOL
Zach says okay random but what's a movie
that made you guys cry
um there's lots honestly
the worst ugly cry that I ever this has
been a while what the what was that
movie that had Anthony Hopkins in it
playing C.S Lewis and it was about him
and his wife Joy I think was her name
and like she died at the end well
spoiler alert but I mean it's like based
on a true story
um man that I would never want to watch
that [ __ ] movie again that was like
it was so [ __ ] sad that was one of
the saddest [ __ ] movies I've ever
[ __ ] seen
um I don't know like any any like even
vaguely sad ending is not like I might
not ball or anything but a lot of them
will kind of make me tear out [ __ ] I
even like cheered up at the end of train
to Busan so and that's a horror movie
like a zombie movie
but that's pretty good like props to
Korea man they made like an excellent
zombie movie that also like made me cry
they had shadowlands thank you that's
the name of it yeah shadowlands
um it was a great movie but I don't ever
want to watch that again not ever
it was so so sad and I don't even I
think you know what it is
um like anytime somebody dies in a movie
well not you know not if it's like a
slasher movie but if it's just like a
drama or something like that and if the
characters are good and if the actors
are good
um then yeah then I'll probably cry at
the end if somebody dies
um unless they were insufferable in
which case I'm like good die
[ __ ] but
um one thing that really like almost
never fails to make me cry in a movie is
if a dude cries you know what I mean
like if their wife dies or some [ __ ] and
then they just can't even handle it and
then they start crying holy [ __ ] I can't
I can't I can't deal with that you know
what I mean but uh yeah
um
Camp guy said medical protocol around
here is full schedule rabies vaccination
if you're exposed to a wild raccoon bat
or possum holy [ __ ]
yeah uh granther said the Elephant Man
turns on my fossil yeah I cried at that
too like I said it's I cried a lot at a
lot of them but the elephant man that's
really really sad too holy [ __ ] I but
like I said pretty much any character
any movie that has like a likable
character that dies at the end yeah and
it's not so much the character dying
that's sad it's the other people
reacting to it that's sad so if like so
if they have the other so I think that's
why shadowlands got me so much because
Anthony Hopkins is just such a good
actor that you know when his wife dies
in the movie and just the way he reacted
man I just couldn't I like I had to
leave like I couldn't even like because
I was like I'm watching the UK actually
like I was at my my ex uh parents-in-law
and we were all watching it and I was
like I was getting like embarrassed
because I was just like yeah that's like
I gotta go I can't [ __ ] deal with
this anymore I know because I was just
like [ __ ] I was just bawling it was
awful
um for me it was hereditary yeah I could
see that that didn't make me cry but
that did um disturb me a lot it gave me
like really bad nightmares for a couple
of uh weeks that [ __ ] me up it that it
didn't make me cry but it made me like
feel really really shitty and weird for
like a couple weeks you know and it did
the second time to you but not as bad as
the first time but I was into it because
I was like well it's a horror movie
that's what it's supposed to do and it
was like a long time since one had done
that so I kind of made me happy in a
weird way uh no time to die Titanic and
the movie about Helen Keller yeah I
cried at the Helen Keller one too and
honestly like it's not even just it
doesn't have to just be like somebody
dying or like something sad happening
like sometimes if something like super
happy happens too like sometimes I'll
cry at that also like depending on what
it is I'm totally I'm a sucker for like
that because you know how sometimes
they'll try to like manipulate your
emotions like with that surging music
and stuff like that that totally works
on me it totally works and I and I know
that I'm being manipulated I'm just like
oh here comes like the the surging
violins and all that kind of stuff and
then I'm like like you know I was like
God damn it
they got me ah
but yeah I just you know uh whale with
Brendan Fraser is supposed to be a tear
maker yeah I I kind of want to see that
but
I don't know I don't know
Schindler's List yeah that was like
really sad too
300
saddest movie I remember seeing recently
says Ben was about an old man and his
cat I think it was called Tonto and me
or something and honestly like the older
I get like I can still watch horror
movies like all day long but I've
noticed that the last few years I've
gotten a lot a lot more sensitive about
like [ __ ] happening to animals and
movies not so much people I don't give a
[ __ ] like if things happen to people in
movies I'm just like yeah whatever but
um yeah it's like every time I see a
movie now where like something [ __ ] up
happens to a cat or a dog I'm just like
oh that's it makes me really really mad
it makes me really bad I saw what was
the movie that I watched the other day
that and I think I reviewed it
um [ __ ] now I can't think of what it was
it might have been like an anthology or
something like that but okay
but there was this thing like it and
like the dog you know something [ __ ]
up happened to the dog oh I remember
what it was it was one of the VHS movies
and if you know if you've seen him you
know which one I'm probably talking
about like the it was the one about the
um it was called slumber party alien
abduction and the [ __ ] up thing that
happened to the dog in that I was just
like oh no absolutely not absolutely not
because I thought the dog was gonna make
it and the dog doesn't make it down
something
she's like don't bring me up here she
tries to get me on the floor
with her yeah she's like come down today
come down to Pookie Lane she said come
down here come out here Pookie laying in
because I go on the floor and I'll feed
her a meat stick yeah these little meat
sticks and she and she starts zoning out
[ __ ] chewing God she loves look at me
she's like your own only the tuna ones
though yeah I mean she'll eat the other
ones because they don't and it's really
weird because they make I think they
only make three flavors or they're not
Sheba are they are they Shiba I think
they are they um I think they only make
three flavors they make chicken salmon
and tuna chicken and salmon are like
really easy to get you can get them at
the grocery store I've seen them at the
Dollar Dollar General all that kind of
stuff but the tuna ones for some reason
are a [ __ ] to find and I have to order
them like on Amazon so I even have like
I think I have
um you know one of the subscriptions
where it comes like I think it comes
like every three weeks or something
because she [ __ ] loves the
m-e-a-t-s-t-i-c-k-s she's wherever she
got mad because um I just kind of spell
things because she's like well I want
one yeah they're not in here though but
um for some reason she really loves the
tuna one so I buy like the big box of
the tuna ones that I have to get ones
like every three weeks because it's a
pretty big [ __ ] crowd in there right
now for as boring as the show's going
I'm gonna it's not boring I'm starting
to get [ __ ] loaded in this [ __ ]
we're gonna have to [ __ ] liven this
up a little bit
it's not important we're talking about
kitties and boobies I think it's what's
boring about that okay what do you want
to talk about talk about anything
talk about anything he doesn't want to
talk about anything oh he's getting
cranked I want to talk about the club
I'm gonna go to the club tonight well
yeah but we're not that's it's not even
seven o'clock would you settle down what
time what time the show gonna end I
don't know okay whatever it is and this
show at about eight okay that's fine and
I'll get us something to eat and then
you can get ready and then we'll go yeah
because like I said all I gotta I
already did my makeup and hair and
everything like that because I know
we're going this time like last week
last week you kind of like sprung it on
me like at the last minute so I had to
like [ __ ] start over but today I like
waited a long time until I put my makeup
on so you know what I mean
Victor thank you Victor let's talk about
grits that's not great
I can make grits go down there and make
grits got time to make grits but I got
other stuff that's already pre-made that
I can jump start
what do you think is I don't want to eat
too much and we eat too much go to the
club [ __ ] looking and feeling fat
I want to go to the club [ __ ] on the
empty stomach
well you don't want to drink on an empty
stomach though okay well we'll get some
I mean but it's good to have something
small because
I like to have something small before we
go because yeah I like to have something
like I don't like to drink on an empty
stomach but also I don't want to drink
too much because I Gotta Wear a corset
and I don't want to feel like I'm gonna
throw up all night you know I mean
so it works out mouth we'll work
something out that works out now
um oh I got thawed hamburger I can make
some little hamburgers okay so that's
fine yeah I mean that's that's small
yeah
um let's see Dave says a really good
Publix commercial brings all the sets
brings all the what the sads like crying
you know what I mean yeah yeah that's
what we were talking about that's what
we were Publix commercial yeah what is
that why is that sad oh which one are
you talking about I don't know what he's
talking about I've seen some commercials
that were sad I'm sure but it's like I
can't really remember what they were
like at the moment
I even like even sometimes remember back
when we were doing the matinee show when
we were going and just seeing like all
the movies like we'd go and see three
movies a week even if we didn't like
necessarily want to see them like even
some of those like [ __ ] cheesy ass
horrible dog movies even that [ __ ] would
like made me cry sometimes because I'm
like oh the dog there was a time we had
that [ __ ] um
AMC Well we still have it we just never
go and we just never go it's far now
it's far and that's the closest one
we need to start going back but you
you're always busy
you know you work [ __ ] all day I know
she because she she ramped up all the
video production because she's making
her own videos now
and [ __ ] there's no time to do any of
that I mean if I knew like because you
know we could probably go but see the
thing about it is like the best day to
go is Saturday but you never want to go
on Saturday because you're like oh
everybody else will be there but I'm
like well not packed well I mean we
don't have to go at night though we
could go like in the daytime it's
jam-packed during the day or Thursday
would work too yeah Thursday would work
Thursday would work too because I don't
have as much to do on that one I hate
that I hate crowded theaters I'd rather
go when it was dead I really do well I
yeah I do too I don't really like to see
I mean every now I'm gonna take a leak
man the [ __ ] bathrooms are terrible
every now and then like sometimes uh
specific horror movies like I've heard
terrifyer too is like really good if you
see it with a big crowd like something
like that that's like really fun and
gory and [ __ ] like that is probably fun
to see with a big crowd but other than
that people are just a source of noise
yeah they make noise they [ __ ] talk
even if they're not talking like they're
like crunching and they're opening bags
and I'm just like Jesus Christ would you
please be quiet we were at one movie the
woman was talking to her dad through the
whole [ __ ] movie and Jenny was like
will you guys please stop talking and
then she got up and tried to [ __ ]
guilt her and [ __ ] about being you know
about telling her to shut up she's you
made more noise about it yeah I was like
you know shut the [ __ ] up we're here
watching the damn movie and it was a
quiet movie like you know what I mean it
was like one that you kind of had to
listen to and I'm just like look this
isn't your [ __ ] living room all right
go the [ __ ] home and watch it if you're
gonna like talk to her no you said
living room that's not it was it was not
their trailer
I wasn't thinking that fast well
trailers yeah trailers out living room
their living room was in a trailer yeah
probably yeah it's like it's I don't
understand like these people but uh
thank you Jeffy art by the way in my VHS
headcanon I want to believe the dog is
found by a deputy responding to a called
and brought to a vet immediately I mean
it could have been they didn't
necessarily say that the dog died but it
looked like the dog died and like that
little whimpering noise that it made I
was like oh no I was like God damn it
because I thought it was gonna get to
the end that like the dog was gonna be
okay because the dog had been through
the whole thing like with the little
camera on his head and [ __ ] like that oh
you know what [ __ ] aliens is damn
Nathan's Hot Dogs open already yeah okay
maybe we'll get one of those huh yeah
that's fine well [ __ ] it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter yeah it's like that's
like hours away yes hours away that's
one hour away
you know well I'm just saying like don't
like rush me you know what I mean I just
kind of feel like I gotta plan ahead
though I do but I gotta have a [ __ ]
plan
when have you ever had a plan friend
I've always had a plan never yeah which
VHS episode is that it was the one that
was I can't remember which movie it was
in but the the name of the segment was
slumber party alien abduction
so was that in 94 or night no yeah maybe
no I can't remember I can't remember
which one it was
um James says I love your crime and
Memorial videos by the way thank you
very much
thank you very much
um Kevin said what is Tom wear a leather
harness [ __ ] only when I'm hanging you
from a [ __ ] ceiling oh
where what just I'm wearing right now
yeah he's just gonna go yeah I'm gonna
go just like this
he's gonna probably go in that
um
Zach says I wish you guys would come to
the gay bar I go to when I went there
for pride month it was like walking into
a [ __ ] David Lynch movie
wait in what way
because everyone
that could be really really good or
really really bad I'm not entirely sure
gay bars are [ __ ] polarizing every
time me and Jenny go [ __ ] um it's
either the music is really awesome or
it's [ __ ] really sucks it's always
some kind of extreme we used to go to
[ __ ] uh Southern Nights which is
actually a [ __ ] that's a straight up
[ __ ] drag theater bar basically I
like Southern yes Southern Nights was
good we had we had a [ __ ] um goth
night going like a fetish name like a
flat fetish goth Knight going on and uh
the music was great
music was great and the bartenders there
were really cool and they would say that
you know they'd [ __ ] have some nights
it was nothing but like 70s disco and
[ __ ] [ __ ] which I could I could I
yeah I could fly with that I could go
with that [ __ ] that'd be fun Abba's
[ __ ] Dancing Queen and [ __ ] YMCA
we'll see now every now and then like
sometimes I don't know if they do this
anymore but sometimes that mannequins
um on Saturday nights because for a
while they would do something called
what the [ __ ] Saturdays and they would
just play like anything you know what I
mean so sometimes you know they'd play
like I don't know like Bauhaus or the
cramps or something like that but then
like uh you know 10 minutes later
they're playing the bgs and I'm kind of
into that like I'm not so into because
like you know playing anything also
entails like oh it's like sometimes
they'd play like [ __ ] [ __ ] from the
90s or I don't know like that pop punk
crap or whatever it was good though man
but some of it was some of it was good
well yeah but some of the stuff and
stuff yeah but that's good 90s I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about
like shitty 90s right you know what I
mean I'm talking about like [ __ ] who
the [ __ ] am I thinking of God damn it
uh
uh who did that song All-Star
All-Star yeah yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] I can't remember but it's
like it's like [ __ ] like that was that
90s or the early 2000s I don't know it's
all a blur it's all a blur when you get
to my age remember Prodigy came out
Smack My [ __ ] Up and [ __ ] yeah that was
what 90s well they still play well they
play that at mannequins too every now
and then like on Saturdays they still
play Smiley and everybody still dances
to it like I don't but like I like some
Die Antwoord Die Antwoord remember them
yeah yeah yeah
because yeah there was a um they usually
play that I think Yolanda I think your
freaky song yeah yeah well there's a lot
of they have a lot of good stuff though
yeah yeah
I mean I would you know
ugly boy I don't know if I'd ever like
and buy anything but some of it's good
uh let me see yeah Ben said yeah that
annoys me at horror film Society
screenings half the people just laugh
like idiots through the whole thing yeah
it's like
I don't understand it man I just I know
that like does just everybody think that
they're
they can just do whatever the [ __ ] they
want to they want to be sitters they
want to be Center Stage yeah it's like
look no they want to entertain they want
to entertain the crowd these are the
same kind of people like I said they
come in mannequins that are like
yeah yeah it's off and then you're gonna
get a kick him off the [ __ ] dance
floor
[ __ ] you can't dance anyway
it's like no one cares about you piss
off yeah stop trying to be the center of
attention I asked the [ __ ] bartenders
Just Dance or don't bartender is [ __ ]
cool as [ __ ] she's she's our age and
[ __ ] she's got big boobs like Jen and
[ __ ] and those girls are out there
doing that and I said what is why why do
they do that and she goes because
they're children
and being just started [ __ ] laughing
yeah that's what it is they're [ __ ]
children well it's a really do you
remember like the last Friday I don't
think I mentioned this but last Friday I
had like a really weird situation come
up where I was out there dance like a
bunch of people were dancing but I was
like out there dancing I don't remember
what song it was
but like this little woman this little
girl
she was probably in her 20s I guess
maybe 30. and she was like tiny tiny she
was like a little girl with like glasses
on and she came in like she was dancing
like right by me and she was like
dancing like me you know what I mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah and I'm like looking
at her and then she kind of like I mean
it's kind of loud I'm just doing what
you doing she's like I was doing what
you're doing and I was like looking at
her like don't you do that don't do that
yeah and then she got she's like oh my
God I'm so sorry but I'm like
what the [ __ ] are you thinking and I'm
like and I'm looking at everybody going
She's a nerd like why I'm like did you
not think that that would come off as
like you being an [ __ ] like you
making fun of me because that's what it
looked like yeah but like I guess she
didn't mean it like that but no because
she I was like it's still weird though
knock it off
[Laughter]
but the deal was is Jenny
was knocked out and this girl was not
okay she was just kind of a what we what
we would call into Gothic [ __ ]
culture of mundane all right which is a
regular person or a normie a normie or a
muggle if you're like one of those Harry
Potter no I'm not [ __ ] you know you
know don't you know I don't mean to be
rude but I use a racial slur like like
a mundane but she was uh kind of a
yuppie what would you call that today I
don't know I don't know I don't know
what the preferred nomenclature is now
yeah because I don't we don't know what
they are we don't know what y'all are
okay we have our own I don't understand
yeah right we don't even that's what I
kept telling like I don't understand I
don't understand like why she thought
right that that would be a good thing
she was approaching it from the point of
view that you were leading a line dance
okay okay that's what it was totally
uncool she's following away totally
totally uncool in the gothic subculture
because the gothic cell culture is not
really so much about that type of
conformity
we conform within the parameters
parameters of the [ __ ] goth aesthetic
okay but but that's pretty wise that's
very broad right the idea is dancing in
Synchro next to one another is like no
no that's very weird that's [ __ ] line
dancing okay that's That's Country okay
yeah we don't do that [ __ ] yeah or maybe
like something on stage some hip hop or
something I don't [ __ ] know I don't
think they would do that one UPS no they
wouldn't even do that
yeah it's like that's maybe like
Madonna's dancing Entourage that's
terribly uncle but it was very uncool
well I was just but I realized it I
didn't understand like what she was
trying to do I'm like
um she's trying to be like you I guess
like I didn't mean me to be mean but I
was just kind of like what is your
daughter's age like I didn't even get
like if I had a daughter again yeah if
you had daughter she'd be your
daughter's age yeah she was 21. well the
thing about it though like I said and
that because we used to get
um particularly like uh when Memento
Mori was at uh was at you know ibar like
downtown we used to get
um like douchebags that would wander in
there and they would very specifically
like come out and dance next to people
like mockingly like they would they
would do like the same kind of stuff oh
and I used to [ __ ] drive them [ __ ]
crazy right I get them and booty ride
them yeah and then they'd be like booty
right now
just try [ __ ] the dude and he's like
whoa whoa whoa this is what you got some
against gay people well I'm not gay this
is you could be gay when I'm [ __ ]
done with you and then they'd want to
run and [ __ ] you know
well yeah because it's like like I said
unicum [ __ ] dance up against me or
her I'm gonna get you in your booty and
like making fun of people yeah like I
said like just everybody like just go
out and dance and just be [ __ ] normal
like just go and dance to the song and
just like you don't gotta be rubbing up
on other people like it's got any
weakness in a man on that dance floor
it's gonna go maximum security
penitentiary real quick you're gonna be
darting my socks for the rest of our
sentence
I'm gonna do it in front of your friends
and then if you [ __ ] come at me then
I'm gonna flip it around and [ __ ]
with the LGBT well you got some against
gay people I'll [ __ ] trip them
because they're totally brainwashed into
all that
because they're afraid the crowd will
turn up against them so I'll [ __ ]
launch an uprising against them so I got
you [ __ ] you come in that club I own
you you piss me off you gotta be my hoe
I just I don't know I just we know all
the owners we're friends with the people
that own the [ __ ] club
a friend with all the security and all
the gangsters and all the bad people are
also my friends
the cops and the criminals are my
friends in those places
Jenny can attest
but uh yeah no
I just thought it was very very strange
yeah because like I said I'm just out
there dancing and listening to music and
having a good time because and then
suddenly I see this little mini me
person like I'm like what are you doing
are you like mocking me that's not cool
and I guess she wasn't but that was like
the first thing because because like I
said douches used to come to momentum
Warrior do that kind of stuff all the
time but it's like I was just kind of
like what are you even thinking like why
would you go up to somebody and do that
it was like just do your own [ __ ]
thing there's one dude I tossed across
the [ __ ] Dance Floor remember that
and that was before I was even big
yeah and then remember that fat boy that
was before I was big
I was a little dude then I [ __ ]
tossed that [ __ ] he was just a little
fat beta and [ __ ] he came up and
[ __ ] dancing ridiculous in front of
me and I was [ __ ] tossed his ass
he was dancing all up in my ass yeah
yeah and security tossed his ass
which I [ __ ] hate that like yeah
please don't ever do that I mean we
shouldn't have to tell those people here
for Christ's sake but that's he thought
he was I don't understand it I just
didn't I don't understand that [ __ ] I
don't understand I don't understand well
like I said that's why I was mystified
by that girl I was just kind of I'm like
looking at everybody going what the [ __ ]
and they're like I don't know man I
don't know what the [ __ ] what would she
think zero comprehension of club culture
zero zero well they don't really it's
not like they must be online only or
something or well the thing about it
like I said we talked about this before
but I think like those kind of people
like some of the people that like come
in mannequins and stuff like that are
just kind of people that hang out at
like sports bars and like I don't know
like other kind of clubs they're not
sure where they are and they're not
really sure yeah like what the etiquette
is clearly so they just like act ass
like when they get in there like they
would act and I guess they get away with
it like in other places because
everyone's acting like an ass and that's
just what you're supposed to they're in
a they're in an environment where
they're not really sure what the rules
are so they just [ __ ] think there are
no rules so they double down and double
down on [ __ ] and then they're bounced
immediately
pretty immediately
yeah
it's pretty easy to intimidate them
though it's like seriously all you have
to do it's like if you you know look
kind of gossed out and stuff and you
just kind of over there like dancing by
them and just like accidentally elbow
him a couple times they'll usually leave
yeah
force of physical confrontation
whoops well they're not really they're
not really attuned to to the inner
dynamics of the [ __ ]
clubs social network we got [ __ ]
David din there he knows what's up we
saw David last week at the [ __ ]
mannequins yeah we were hanging out of
the
up at the bar he says that listen to us
is better than e radio
it is because because we we all know
each other
but uh it was it was funny to be next to
up at the bar
next to a [ __ ] regular listener who
is also local that we know it's just
weird yeah I've known Dave a long time
yeah I think I met him before I met you
even yeah he probably knows me a lot
better than I know him because everyone
was listening to a long time you know
what I mean [ __ ] I spill my guts on
this [ __ ]
together who I am if you've been
listening to you for years like some of
you all have yeah we say all kind of I
guess I'll get [ __ ] messages out of
the blue
through social media of dudes that I
don't [ __ ] know who the dude is but
he knows me like I'm his buddy you know
well like I said I appreciate it though
when you do it that's right I appreciate
it I appreciate it because that's what
happens like when you come on here and
like talk about and like I said
sometimes like you know especially on
the side track shows like we've had a
few drinks and [ __ ] like that it's like
we just start like saying all kind of
crap I don't even remember most of the
[ __ ] we said on here I'm sure we said
all kind of horrible horrible things now
hit me up with inside jokes and talk
about something I said yeah yeah yeah
and sometimes I don't even remember
sometimes I'm like oh [ __ ] did I say
yeah yeah some of the [ __ ] I don't
remember but I was like yeah that sounds
about right and then we'll talk a little
bit and [ __ ] then vanish you know
it's just there's a lot of fans
um and then like some of them are
[ __ ] stuck like that's how we met
Sophie yeah
um and there was some people from just
all over the world you know
Sophie over the years has become real
good friends of ours she's like
birthday presents and [ __ ] Christmas
presents and [ __ ] and she's been down a
couple times and
you know
sometimes but me and Soph had friends in
in in in from Michigan and yeah because
you lived in Michigan yeah one of her
friends was like the little sister one
of my best friends up there so yeah but
she didn't know that when she became a
listener just over time she pieced that
together that yeah I lived I lived in
her area I knew same people she knew so
that was that was a trip
just
and then uh talking to people in
Australia uh
uh UK
South and Central America down as far as
[ __ ] Argentina
just Korea
because I lived in Korea for a while so
we got a couple uh what was what was the
name Miss Kim where did she came I think
they're all they missed Kim I forgot who
was she she's a regular
um it's just kind of funny how
you end up kind of people end up knowing
us you know
thing we're kind of like on here just
talking about like I don't we don't
script these like even the even the
recorded videos like you know I put up a
video of us talking about the Boris
Karloff movie The Mummy we didn't script
that I mean you know what I mean we just
like sit here and record it so it's this
is kind of like uh what you see is what
you get kind of thing like this is
pretty much exactly what we're like in
real life like if you know us in real
life yeah we're pretty much exactly like
this we're not any different no we're
more fun in person
well that's true that's a club that's
true because on the yeah I mean yeah
we're just kind of like we're not in a
studio yeah and there's a lot more
people and then we're around our our
friends what's funny is like our our
friends friends and don't listen to the
show or something but they got their own
projects civilian friends
Our God friends don't most of them don't
really listen to the show but they're
all running their own things they got
their own bands and we don't listen to
all their [ __ ] all the time either it's
kind of like we're all part of the
circus and we're well yeah because
everybody like I like to try and keep up
with people's stuff but it's just kind
of like there's a lot of people that are
creators like there's artists and
writers and closed clothing makers
clothing maker is like yeah makers
everybody's like has their musicians
[ __ ] going on and so it's like yeah we
know a lot of people in bands and stuff
like yeah so we all hang out together
but we don't we can't closely follow
their [ __ ] because we're working
but it's like we're all like part of the
circus and they're all goths
most of them some of them are but uh but
they're all just cool people you know
Kevin said what is the popular goth
where these days steampunk uh steampunk
is gone that's been gone yeah
um they will do a steampunk event every
now and then I actually just did a
poster for like an industrial steampunk
thing they want to do but that's usually
like a once in a blue moon thing where
people will dress up like that but I
don't I haven't seen anybody wear
steampunk stuff for maybe 10 years
yeah maybe not quite that long
but I don't know it's kind of like all
over the place I have seen like kind of
a Resurgence of more
um kind of death Rock stuff like from
the 80s uh particularly among like
younger the younger people like you know
the bigger hair and like the Susie eyes
and all that kind of stuff uh faux hawk
a lot of faux hawks like yeah like
ripped fishnets like leather jackets all
that all that kind of stuff but it's
really kind of like across the board um
you asked if uh a kilt would fly yeah uh
we actually know a couple guys that wear
kilts pretty regularly what makes a goth
outfit is not the clothes it's always
the boots it's always the boots yeah we
talked about we talked about that
earlier you gotta have pair of [ __ ]
demonias or new rocks or some old flu
vogs fluvogs did cool [ __ ] remember
destroy remember those yeah yeah it was
kind of like
there there's uh you can get those on
Etsy there are people selling old ones
they still look brand new because they
were all leather destroyed and flew
remember how expensive flu bugs were
yeah they're still like 700 for some of
those flu bugs Jesus Christ yeah and
they're not that cool
they can't be that [ __ ] awesome they
look kind but some some of the stuff
that's out there that's used you can get
for like 150 200 and it's like buying a
pair of new rocks they last 30 or 40
years you can wear them every day better
because everything is so you know
there's no synthetics in them so
everything can be repaired but they have
that same look that you would see from
like demonias
remember pedaggling yeah remember those
gone now I think but a lot of demonias
are copies of Pentagon uh
now that I [ __ ] remember it but you
know
it's the Footwear the Footwear is
[ __ ] 90 of it so if you have a good
pair like say
I would if I was gonna wear a [ __ ]
Kilt I wouldn't really [ __ ] with demonia
I'd [ __ ] with new rock
it's classier more expensive get you a
pair of 300 [ __ ] knee-high boots wear
that but like I said they last longer
they last forever like this this I got a
pair I got two pair but that's what they
look like yeah and like I said those
were what 300 350 3 3 40 350 I think but
you've had those a long time yeah it's
been about eight years probably yeah
you've had this right and they get
better as they get older it's all real
leather Spanish made stuff
and um because they always kind of look
alike they don't really go out of style
you know you know new rock when you see
it and you'll see most of your metal
guys on stage all those bands where they
wear new rock you know well see that's
what I always thought was like kind of
cool about like the goth scene is that
it has its own
um
I guess it has its own things that go in
and out of fashion yeah but
some things never do and I kind of feel
like it's like a much wider like you
could get away with wearing some [ __ ]
like you could turn up from like uh
looking like 90s you know you could do
full 90s goth regalia or whatever like I
said you could come in looking like
[ __ ] early 80s death Rock like alien
sex being kind of [ __ ] you could do that
and it's like everybody like all right I
suppose so you know what I mean so it's
not just kind of like oh my God that was
so last year like nobody really does
that you know what I mean but like I
said there are things that go in and out
of style but because I remember like for
a Time
uh okay now there is one thing that
people wore a lot that nobody wears
anymore
um in the 2000s I kind of feel like in
the early 2000s mid-2000s when the whole
Graver uh kind of thing was going was
big which I never really got into
because I don't like that but
um a lot of people like a lot of girls
it's mostly girls would wear those kind
of like knee-high like fur you know what
I mean like they put like boots on but
then like there'd be like these
things that you put on your legs that
were just like this big fur thing it
looks kind of cool like I guess but I
don't know I had a pair for a while but
I only wore them a couple times because
I was like man this isn't really my look
you know what I mean
um but you never see anybody wearing
those anymore never
um I mean if you did like I don't think
anybody would like [ __ ] on you or
anything like that but I just haven't
seen them in a really long time so
that's one thing that I can think of
that people that people don't wear
anymore
uh did you guys ever review Dr sleep I'm
pretty sure we did um it might have been
like a matinee show now it might have
been like one of the old matinee shows
where we saw it in the theater because
we saw that in the theater but I don't
know we might have done another show on
it like after because Tom bought it on
uh Blu-ray and he just like um kept
talking about how much better the
director's cut was so I'm kind of
thinking that we did another version but
maybe not
Victor said whatever happened to that
German lady that would make the long
usernames yeah Sandra whatever happened
to her like the the peanut butter girl
that's what I was wondering too and uh
and Tila she's she's not around anymore
either I don't know why I don't know if
it's just because their schedules
changed or they got sick of listening to
us or I don't really know
I don't really know Danny Rowling said
could black Timberland boots pass for
goth probably not no probably not no
there's certain brands you have to be
real dark in there yeah certain brands
and certain looks so you got to go
through if you're poor and you can't
afford and we're not saying this with a
derogatory
sense because [ __ ] everybody has them
in the scene if you don't have a lot of
money you got to go with demonia demonia
boots that's easy they're not made real
well if you wore that every weekend for
a year they'd probably fall apart
but a lot of people have a bunch of
demonia Footwear yeah I have several and
they rotate them you know I don't wear
them
and you'll get more years out of them
you know
uh the good thing about demonias is
accessible the Fashion's pretty good on
them
um
but they're accessible you can get them
prices are only about 100 bucks for a
good pair
and um you get a lot of selection they
make a lot of different things
so you you'll find something that'll fit
an outfit the real good [ __ ] like new
rock they all look pretty much the same
they're just different heights different
stuff on them but it's all that same
style and it's three times the price but
they last forever and they haven't
changed in [ __ ] decades
you know I mean they're kind of classic
you know what I mean just like [ __ ]
Doc Martens like you can still get you
can wear Doc Martens and nobody would
say boo you know what I mean because
that's like a very classic design you
could even wear the color the the
different colored ones because I had a
pair I have a red pair and I have a blue
and uh green plaid pair too from what I
saw in Etsy going
vintage only an expert Guff who's been
around a long time wouldn't know the
difference between what you could wear
today and what you could
uh some of the fluvog and its girls of
flu bugs now guys girls
because they didn't really make guy's
shoes this is back in the day back in
the 90s they were guys weren't in the
market
girls had all the cool [ __ ] back in
those days but the some of the flu vogs
you see on there that you can get used
for a hundred and something dollars
are all leather they would be 300 now
probably they're still in great
condition the ones that they're selling
and it looks like something you would
buy today from demonia a little more
simple but better quality uh real
leather
and also destroy which was a 90s brand
destroy looked like Pentagon and new
rock kind of is what they look like and
they
were just these evil looking
boots for girls that had big cleats on
them and metal and they can't they were
leather and they came in different
colors like [ __ ] black or black with
blue and
it was just called destroy go get 90s
destroy
Footwear shoes or boots women and Google
it you'll see it'll come up
they'll probably be on Etsy
and they're going to be bidding on them
and that shit's decades old and you look
at it looks brand new
because that's how well that's how good
that's they think they were British I
think
that's how good Footwear used to be they
were like handcrafted made out of real
[ __ ] real leather
leather lasts a long [ __ ] time
yeah if you take care of it Kevin said
um there's leather boots out there over
100 years old you could wear
and walk around in them they're out
there Kevin said do you see anyone
wearing the German tie-dyed super tight
jeans like skinheads no no
I was saying I was saying that one thing
that you don't see anymore that you used
to see everywhere was those knee-high
fur things remember those those were
cute though yeah but I'm just saying
that was mostly a Graver thing and you
don't really see you don't see cyber
[ __ ] anymore really nice I mean if you
did if somebody came up like in full
like cyber regalia like nobody would
think that was weird necessarily but you
don't see it anymore like nobody usually
wears that but whereas when I used to go
to the castle like in the early 2000s
you used to see that a lot like you're
talking about the boots that were made
out of fur well they're not boots but
they're those I had a pair remember
those like red and black oh the leggings
the leggings
that you are over the boots yeah it's
kind of been gone for a while yeah
that's what I was saying that's one
thing because I was trying to think of
like something they're not out though no
that's what I'm saying but it's like you
just don't see them in the wild anymore
like I said if you wore them like I
don't think anybody would look at you
weird but you'd have to be in the full
outfit yeah you would need kind of the
full cyber like I said if somebody came
out of like a full cyber and they had
like [ __ ] you know circuits and [ __ ]
in their hair and [ __ ] like that like
everybody be like oh cool you know what
I mean throwback date it's throwback
right yeah but like nobody would think
it was strange but you just don't see
anybody wearing them just like casually
anymore but but I remember like for a
while you did like a lot of girls wore
them I was so and so photographs of real
90s era goth girls
and how good goth was back in those days
how pretty those girls were and what
they wore was very tasteful
and a lot of it wouldn't be considered a
lot of it would be considered kind of
normal clothes today a lot of the stuff
that they wore it wasn't back in the day
though
um yeah it's funny how weird it seemed
back then now you look at it it's not
weird at all not weird at all but they
were
um Real femi by today's standards
um
they were they were cute and and I
forgot how young they were I was there
at the time and they were just my peers
I forgot how young we were
that uh just look just Google 90s goth
fashion
and photo photographs are real people
going to the club and the guys and the
girls will come up if you then you put
images on Google and it'll come up and
it was uh I forgot how tasteful it was
but it was still definitely goth
definitely with the bangs and the long
hair with bangs and uh Pony Falls and
[ __ ] like that they were just it was
just a good time
pretty pretty decent I do still like all
the pony Falls so if you don't see that
as much anymore but like I said I still
have some yeah because like I said if
you see some of those pictures of like
the girls with like those really big
long hair with all the colors and stuff
like that those are just clip-on
ponytails because I have some like that
too you just put your real hair into
little like buns and then you just it
just Clips over like that it's like
super easy and actually this hair here
this is mostly my hair the bangs are my
hair but this little puff that's that's
fake
but my real hair is like underneath
there I put them in like little things
and then put like the bigger just to
give it some volume you know what I mean
Rebecca says uh good morning y'all
aren't you because she's in Australia
aren't you kids heading out to
mannequins yeah we are in a little while
it's it's a little bit it's 7 20. okay
it's a little bit early still but yeah
we're gonna we're gonna knock off here
probably around eight probably like
eight ish and then because we gotta like
eat something before we go but I don't
want to get there like too too early
well I don't know what time did we leave
last time nine yeah when we got there it
was about the time remember we still had
it's pretty dead when we got there yeah
but I was able to find parking had it
been later it would have been more
difficult that last time we went oh you
didn't know that was a big event well
yeah that was Halloween we were lucky to
be able to find parking yeah we thought
we were gonna have to come back home
because we're gonna find any [ __ ]
place to park right because the whole
street was closed off because they were
having a big carnival or whatever
uh Danny Rowling said that whole early
Millennium fad of plastic luggage
looking backpacks and goggles look was
stupid in my opinion yeah I didn't love
it I didn't I didn't really love
um
the cyber goth thing or the perky goth
thing
can work some of it did some of it was
good some of it looks good but like the
real cyber [ __ ] where it's just kind of
like everything was like goggles and
those big like neon colored furry things
and just they were putting all that
stuff in their hair like tubes and wires
and all that kind of stuff like I don't
know it depends like sometimes it looks
cool always dependent on the person but
it depended on the person and like what
the look was I didn't love like all the
neon because I don't really like any of
that real I don't like that raver [ __ ] I
don't like any of that stuff it always
depended on the person there were some
gorgeous people that could put that on
and they just look [ __ ] fantastic
uh but that's not normally what you had
normally you had people that you really
shouldn't be dressing like that doing
that
okay they just didn't have the level of
physical fitness and
you could only get away with that [ __ ]
if you were [ __ ] basically tall thin
and beautiful then you could like and
very young and young yeah then you could
get away with that yeah once you were
once you were Pat like in your late to
late 20s like or something like that get
into your 30s and [ __ ] didn't work
anymore
and like you said it looked way better
on all that cyber [ __ ] looked way better
on like tall skinny girls tall skinny
girls yeah that's that looks way better
on them on other people not so much like
I said it depends on the person but I
don't like that look in general but it
does work on some people
you know I was I was usually more I'm
kind of more of like a classic goth like
Victorian stuff I like Victorian stuff I
like death Rocky looking stuff some more
kind of dark Punk kind of thing I like
kind of a Glam kind of thing I like that
kind of stuff you know what I mean I
don't really so much like the Cyber
industrial kind of end of stuff although
some people really do pull it off but it
depends on the person but it's just like
personally I'm not real into that and
honestly I really like like I said I
like a lot I like kind of the Cabaret
stuff that was real in in like the
mid-2000s and I really liked um
I don't know I kind of feel like there
was a what was the other thing that I
was thinking oh and I really like kind
of the psycho Billy I like the
Psychobilly kind of look too which is
kind of like rockabilly but horror you
know what I mean I like that too like
that usually looks good and that usually
looks good on like short curvy girls you
know that kind of look because it's very
50s inspired
but you know I like that as well
uh Rebecca said side note I did manage
to view that Netflix series about that
family that hanged themselves in Delhi
yeah gee I I need to watch the rest of
that too the poor cops and crime scene
people in that case you would never get
that out of your head yeah I I really
felt bad for them like I just watched
like the first two episodes and I was
just kind of like holy [ __ ] I can't
imagine yeah I can't imagine like seeing
that like you would never
you would never be able to like not
unsee that you know what I mean and that
ugh ugh they probably like go their
whole [ __ ] career and not see
anything like that it's just horrifying
even imagining it is just like stressing
me out
Zach says uh I remember wearing track
track suits oh remember wearing track
suits and bedazzled everything was a
huge fad same with wearing a t-shirt
over a long sleeve shirt with blonde
highlights none of which looked good
yeah I didn't actually mind
the shirt like the short sleeve shirt
over the long sleeve shirt because I
kind of feel like that was a little bit
like when I was in high school there was
kind of like that was kind of like a
more skater thing so that's like what
skater kids were doing like skater boys
so I didn't mind that as much even
though I'm not real into like skater
culture or anything but I thought that
looked okay and that was actually like a
good thing if you wanted to wear like a
cool band t-shirt but it was cold
outside which she didn't you don't
usually have that problem in Florida but
every now and then you do and so then
you could kind of wear like a long
because I think I did it a couple of
times too like if it was cold out like
you just wear like a like a regular long
sleeve shirt or like a fishnet shirt
underneath and then like you wear a band
t-shirt over it
but yeah Zach said when I was a kid I
had single shirts that were decided to
look like that yeah I thought they made
some that were like when I was in school
like you didn't I don't think they made
any that looked like that you just had
to link to it by yourself
it's just funny it's funny because
I honestly I didn't even
um we didn't where I grew up we didn't
even have like a Hot Topic until
I want to say like the late 90s Maybe
um so before that like I usually had to
mail order clothes or you had to like go
to like a thrift store and like put some
[ __ ] together or what I used to do a lot
was I would go to like Ross or Marshalls
or something like that because a lot of
times they would have
um
you know dresses and [ __ ] like that for
you know fifteen twenty dollars and
sometimes like if you found cool ones
like black ones you could kind of either
like cut them up or you could like
combine them with other things or
something like that like I actually
found some really cool
[ __ ] like that you know what I mean that
you wouldn't think but if you paired it
with certain accessories and shoes and
stuff like it looked really awesome
uh Zach's like also cargo pants yeah I
remember those I remember those I mean
yeah I didn't really get
Rebecca said we still don't have a Hot
Topic [ __ ] Australia well Hot Topic I
don't think it's gone I haven't been
well no it's still around but it's like
I haven't been in one in a really long
time last time I went in one
um yeah it's not like it hasn't been it
hasn't had any golf stuff for a really
long time when it first kind of appeared
in the U.S you could get golf closer
yeah like I got some there like some
Court not real corsets but they had kind
of like just this show corsets you know
what I mean like those kind of topics
they didn't have boned stuff you had to
get that from like from Europe
um
but you couldn't it was the stores
weren't that good what was good was the
online shop
and that's really where the best God
stuff was in the 90s for for uh uh
Hot Topic if you went to that store
there wouldn't be enough selection but
if you went online they had [ __ ] five
times the selection
and that was the time where it [ __ ]
that must have been uh 97 I think maybe
I think it might have been 97 98
I was blown away
because I was buying
me and my ex-wife my first wife buying
us clothes online with a debit card from
Hot Topic and have it delivered to the
house
and I was like well where the [ __ ] are
these malls for
it was mind-blowing I felt like I was in
[ __ ] an Arnold Schwarzenegger [ __ ]
sci-fi movie I thought it was in [ __ ]
Total Recall or something it was a trip
which now you can have literally
anything
right it's like here bring in my
groceries thank you when that's half an
hour later yeah we feel [ __ ] high
tech as [ __ ]
doing that right we cheated man we got
we got the [ __ ] we didn't go to the
store and just paid for it with this
yeah and then they brought it to us you
know suckers yeah
[ __ ] them all and we were in Mississippi
okay and [ __ ] retail
and it was mind-blowing before that you
could order it through like goth
catalogs yeah I used to get Rose yeah
and I've actually I've a long time ago
like I actually went to their store like
and came to Market Market in London I
don't know if it's still there anymore
expensive it was but yeah you had to
like save up and what was that other one
um I had like remember cambriel
camber was a friend of mine yeah yeah
Austin she used to make that [ __ ] yeah I
had one of her dresses like a green
velvet one that had like these really
awesome like Bell sleeves with all this
lace in it and stuff I don't have it
anymore because it's really old but
Cambria was kind of like the uh goth
version she's still around she's still
around yeah she's a cute little girl
back in those days she's a grown woman
now but she was a little bitty cute goth
girl that was kind of like a
20-something year old
Gothic
um
uh who's a girl from [ __ ] Fleetwood
Mac [ __ ] uh Stevie Nicks like a
little Stevie Nicks is what she was like
she would kind of sell
kind of uh
witchy fairy kind of well she likes
medieval medieval kind of stuff which I
like that too yeah like medieval like
Renaissance Fair like I said the dress
that I got from her was it was like she
was in then in the night it was real
velvet and it was green it was like this
really pretty like emerald green velvet
and it was like off the shoulder like
that and then it had like long sleeves
and it had like Belle with like lace in
it and then it was like about knee
length yeah and she I love that dress
they do layouts on her I think on Gothic
Beauty and yeah
and I think she's kind of famous like in
the gospel was she in uh propaganda
magazine probably yeah you guys don't
know what the [ __ ] we're talking about
see back in the day before the internet
we had our own [ __ ] fanzines and
magazines
and you had to subscribe to them and
they would come irregularly most of them
well propaganda only came out like four
times four times a year yeah quarterly
and that was mostly photography there
was articles in there too but that was
mostly because the guy that put it
together was like a photographer and
that was like yeah I used to really like
it though a lot of it was centered
around [ __ ] John koviak and his
handsome ass who was
kind of like a pen pal slash
friend of
Tanya and Tanya was [ __ ] voltaire's
ex-wife but during those times she she
hadn't met him yet it was just she was
my buddy Tanya I'll show you a picture
Tanya Tanya worked for Chanel she was a
Chanel girl and she'd hang out at
[ __ ] man ray in Boston
she was cool but she ended up hooking up
with uh if you guys know who it is a
famous goth dude named um Voltaire
Voltaire he has he has a very interest
he has a like a really fun uh Channel
yeah he's a musician like his I like his
songs like he's hilarious like he write
it's almost like goth but it's funny you
know what I mean like he has got comedy
in it too like really clever lyrics like
yeah he's really funny and he has a
channel on YouTube
um called Gothic homemaking and he like
makes things and like does decorating
and goes around to different like gothi
bars he lives in New York City yeah and
um you know so and they're super fun
like he's our age or older yeah he's my
age but he still looks he looks good
though I think yeah and he's sometimes
opposed to us well you know no yeah no I
didn't say I know he's he's in good
shape he is doing good he is yeah I
thought I had some Tanya in here I don't
have any time
Rebecca said I've been burned buying
clothes online sizing this shape is
never the same I need to try my clothes
on for the right shape in a store yeah I
mean I'm you got to take a chance though
because yeah I mean sometimes you are 75
of the time [ __ ] turns out okay yeah or
I can work with it 25 of the time yeah
if you kind of live out in the middle of
nowhere there will be no opportunities
zero for you to get your hands on a
decent clothes retail
you know I'll be shot yes it's gonna be
shopping down there at the mall I always
kind of wish that I had the patience to
like learn how to sew because my mom
could sew like she could sew anything
probably still can if she wanted to but
um yeah she used to make her Halloween
costumes and like all kind of stuff and
I was like man I really couldn't feel
like I should learn to do that and it's
like I took I don't remember if it was
junior high or high school but I took um
homak and they had like a sewing uh
semester and man I was like [ __ ]
tragically bad at that I don't know why
it's like I don't
I'm not my little hands are just not
that coordinated
[Laughter]
the things but I can't do like little
fiddly anything that has to do with like
little fiddly stuff it's like I can't I
can't [ __ ] do it
um yeah granther says the New York Times
calls Voltaire the Martha Stewart of
goth Home Design yeah he's written a
couple books too I have like he's
written these like cute little books he
did one about just God fault culture and
fashion and he did one about Gothic
decorating like he had like all these
little DIY projects in there and like
all these like ideas and stuff but yeah
he's like really fun to watch he's like
super cute he's like he's like your goth
Dad yeah okay here's some 90s God stuff
I took this down at Man Ray in Boston
that is switchblade Symphony up there on
stage but you can see in front of me in
the crowd a bunch of young Goths all in
basically handmade clothing
with the little hats and stuff well you
had to yeah
like I said most of my [ __ ] came from
like thrift stores yeah you can back in
the 80s and 90s you could see the back
of those hats and everything that girls
wearing
but that's Tina root up there on stage
who's long gone now
switched by Symphony was a great band
they were very good
did you [ __ ] up the lighting again okay
it's okay I think it readjusted itself
but yeah he's um one of my favorite one
of my favorite videos that Voltaire did
was what the one where he um totally
redecorated his bathroom I mean he has
his bathroom it's like basically it's a
New York apartment so it's like the size
of a postage stamp but he really like
kitted it out he even has like his own
wallpaper
that he sells like his own wallpaper
design that he sells on um I can't
remember what the [ __ ] is the name of
that site it's kind of one of those ones
like Cafe Press or Redbubble or
something like that but it's not that
it's something else but he has like some
wallpaper that he sells and he like
wallpapered it it's like black and white
and purple and it's like really cool and
he's just it looked really cool like in
a very very small space so
uh Rebecca said me too Jenny I'm
constantly wishing I had listened to my
mom when she wanted me to help her use a
sewing machine now I'm like I need to
take the summer mate curtains oh wait it
can't so yeah I mean I probably don't
have time now to learn obviously but
I tried to learn before and it was like
really frustrating so I was kind of like
oh well I'm just gonna like pay and like
have other people make [ __ ] for me
I did like a couple of things but like
one time when I was a kid I made
um a kimono like out of uh tablecloth
and it actually like came out and I was
like surprised I was very proud of
myself but
and I think like a long time ago my
grandmother even bought me do you guys
remember like I don't even remember what
this was it was late 80s or early 90s
um they had like those infomercials
where it was like a sewing machine but
it was like a handheld one you know what
I mean where you could just kind of go
go you know it was just for like hemming
things and whatnot and my grandmother
bought me one of those and I made like a
whole like I said I made a couple of
outfits with that because I was like
um you know it wasn't great but it
worked it worked
um yeah Rebecca said it bored the living
[ __ ] out of me yeah that too it's like I
don't have like I'm like one of the
world's most impatient people like
seriously if I can't if I can't do
something like immediately I'm just kind
of like [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm just like you
know I don't have time for this so
um sewing is just kind of like
I I just don't have the patience for it
I just don't you know what I mean it's
funny because I was watching a video the
other day and she was talking about
um I guess it was like that girl that
was doing she was doing like a cheap
Thanksgiving or something like that and
she was making a centerpiece so she was
doing like flower arranging like for the
middle of the table for Thanksgiving and
she's she sat on there she's like
um doing like flower designing or like
you know doing a centerpiece oh it's so
relaxing I'm like I bet I would not be
relaxed doing that I bet it would just
like [ __ ] stress me out
I could just see myself like being like
this looks wrong ah I'd be like throwing
[ __ ] around it like that it's like I
don't know why am I like this I don't
know I just am but like [ __ ] like that
that people sit like gardening and all
that kind of stuff I can't imagine that
that would ever be relaxing I'm sure it
is for some people but I don't think I
would find it relaxing I think I would
just find it frustrating and stressful
I find most things frustrating and
stressful now that I think about it I
can't really think about anything that I
can't really think about anything that I
find particularly relaxing the only
thing I find particularly relaxing is
just kind of like laying down drinking
coffee reading a book that's about it
everything else is just like a source of
horrible frustration and stress
which is probably bad
but yeah I don't really get it look at
puke what is she doing laying on her
back like you're a gummy bear what is it
with you what are you being you all got
me down
she's gonna wig he's here can we see her
yeah no she turned back over anyway yeah
she's like she's laying her she's like
that and like a little gummy bear and
what we say about it she's just like oh
yeah
yeah yeah that's right I was being a
gummy bear yeah
she's such a goofball
um yeah Rebecca said I have to wait for
a dopamine hit to do things I'm not into
and even then I'm not enjoying it [ __ ]
that and I just don't living my best
life yeah that's like the best ADHD life
yeah I do kind of feel like
I don't know what he said he's rocking
our shirt yeah yeah I know it's like I
hope we're like not like offending
people we're not trying to be like you
know so it's not racist necessarily
worst being like it's just another it's
just a subculture and we grew up in it
basically well and like I said the weird
thing is that I don't really know like
how
because I know for a time but even my
parents like in the 80s like they were
okay with it they were just kind of like
okay that's her thing
um and they didn't like tell me to be
different or nothing like that but I
think deep down they thought that I was
gonna grow out of it and I'm like a lot
a lot of people don't though no our
culture actually our generation actually
forced it into the mainstream yeah we
went the opposite way we made you guys
we made you guys so I can like it
because a lot of us ended up in
Hollywood and they started [ __ ]
pushing that they're making movies and
[ __ ] and making movies and they start
and then and then um of course musicians
and and artists and everything started
bringing it more to the mainstream and
it changed you all's fashion a lot
a lot of the stuff you guys wear and
we're like yeah we would award that back
in the 90s now that's mundane clothes
yeah we would have worn that we would
have worn that back in the day
that's just really funny how that
happened that's really funny how that
happened well it's like Revenge because
I was like well back in the 80s like
everybody just thought I was Satanist so
yeah but they liked it I guess yeah they
throw [ __ ] at you from a car window they
would yeah but then they go and they'd
[ __ ] throw bottles albums and [ __ ]
the head are kind on it and [ __ ] they
start buying clothes yeah and
um
and it it was
it started out
mostly kind of an Anglo thing but it
just spread everywhere Central and South
America loved it there are Mexican Goths
that [ __ ] compete with [ __ ]
European and Northern Gods Northerners
man they got that whole day of the dead
they got the whole debt going on they
got the whole shaboo that's very good
that and the [ __ ] okay I'm gonna show
you guys so they're primed yeah Blaster
one set a lot of guys over here would
get teased or bashed for looking
different they did hear as well not I
probably not nowadays
um I kind of feel like everybody knows
what it is now but back in the 80s and
90s
um yeah like you know we like you said
we've gotten you've gotten stuff thrown
at you from cars I've gotten stuff
thrown at me from Cars I had
um I've never been beaten up but I had
um a friend in high school who um he had
like the Robert Smith hair and the
eyeliner and everything like that uh and
he got beat up
several times uh by jock type people but
that was like back in the late 80s early
90s like right around there
um so it did happen I don't think it
happened so much over here anymore but
um because like I said everybody knows
what it is but like in the 80s
when I was at school and like looking
like that nobody
um they didn't have any context for it
you know what I mean it's not like
nobody had seen a Tim Burton movie yet
or anything like that so everyone just
thought you were and you know it was
very much satanic Panic so everyone just
thought that you were a Satanist because
they didn't get it
because no one had heard of the bands
that you liked nobody knew like nobody
had seen any movies with Goths in them
or anything like that so nobody like
knew what that was they just thought you
were a weirdo that worshiped Satan or
killed puppies or something like that so
A lot of times they would just be like I
don't understand it so I'm gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of you so yeah it did
happen it didn't like I said I didn't
get beat up but I know a lot of people
that did
and I did get bottle thrown at me from
Cars so
when I was just walking down the street
going to wherever
so uh Blaster one said yeah I'm a 77 kid
that's when you were born
okay so you're only five years younger
than me then I was born in 1972.
yeah kind of awesome said A week ago
there was a massive Day of the Dead
parade in Mexico City it's now become an
International Event I mean it's so
[ __ ] cool it's such a great [ __ ]
idea okay you can go on Instagram and
her her name is Loretta Vamps
and that's a Mexican goth girl look at
that [ __ ] Mexican cowboy bandito
outfit and everything yeah see that's
awesome all right
so goth can manifest itself in any
culture
well because it's a universal human
thing you know what I mean to darken
things you take your culture you kind of
darken it and but then you kind of make
it cool well it's and also it's kind of
like an acceptance and a romantic
romanticizing of like death or or things
that most people don't want to yeah
think about and you you take your own
culture to a new level look at that look
how awesome that is with the headdress
and everything that looks fantastic yeah
although I always going down amongst the
crypts all I can think like when I see
that is like I should go to the bathroom
look at that that's what I would be no
you just have to walk around that outfit
but she makes personal appearances and
everything and then she's got the
Mexican Uncle Fester see that looks
pretty awesome yeah yes indeed they're
walking down through the Crips
and then there are other ones with her
see I want to go to Mexico man I'm gonna
[ __ ] experience that [ __ ]
that is badass somebody else's
interpretation of goth you [ __ ] up the
lighting again it'll be good it'll be
okay
and then uh well look at look how
awesome this is don't worry about it
because I got to do it again look how
awesome this outfit is
okay
and then she even dresses up like a like
a chill little clown
same girl I don't like that as much
they're doing low rider stuff I know
they're doing low rider stuff not really
my thing yeah
yeah okay
this is a weird this is a weird one
kind of a Day of the Dead motif
I think it's very creative
very original
okay
Rebecca says uh until my late 20s uh I
everything I wore was different shades
and textures of black and people used to
think I was depressed I just like black
and black likes me I started wearing
color and people started freaking out
yeah that's the thing too is
when I was in high school
um one of my teachers I'm not naming her
but she narked on me to the guidance
counselors they brought me to guidance
because they thought I was like suicidal
or something like that because I wore
black clothes and was reading pet
cemetery
in the 80s I was like really okay
everybody reads Stephen King come on now
I mean I could see if it was something
like [ __ ] I don't know like really
[ __ ] up or it's even then it's like
yep I was like back off [ __ ] leave me
alone I hated that [ __ ] she was one of
my least favorite teachers I'm not
saying what her name was but
fixture says when you paint your face
for Dia de los Muertos but everyone
thinks you're Kung Fu Panda
and said that event it's always on
Saturday on the last week of October
first week of November and it's packed
yeah that's the thing it's just I mean
it's like such a cool idea but yeah
everybody it'd be like like I said going
out for Halloween ever I'm sorry I keep
doing that but it's like I can't stand
that the lighting is messed up and it
looks permanent to me no it's too bright
look how look how HD it is it looks
awful you're just not used to it yeah
you guys like that better or do you like
I don't want to be that way I don't like
that
it looks all [ __ ]
looks all [ __ ] up because it's too
sharp huh
well no it's like kind of washed out it
looks all washed out okay yeah you're
not getting any contrast everything's
like all washed out I don't like it
I don't like it but it didn't do it I
bend it when it it won't it won't go
back you keep [ __ ] it up because you
keep like [ __ ] my focus up look at
how much she complains she blames
everything on me well you're the one
that did it no no it's the same okay
it's the same I'm teaching that [ __ ]
how to [ __ ] it's the same as it was
there you go there finally oh Jesus
Christ it went back now quit messing
with it quit messing with it
um let's see
yeah I mean that yeah kind of awesome
said this last one was a record breaker
in attendance it's televised Nationwide
it's a big thing here like your
Tournament of Roses Parade in a way
yeah that's why it says we look great
yeah I don't like that I don't like that
he's kind of looking
yeah but okay
that only happens because it doesn't
know like what the focus is now like I'm
used to just having it like this because
this is what it's usually like that's
what we only got another 10 minutes
before we got close Showdown anyway
that's true
but you know
we didn't even hardly even talk about
food today
we'll make some food
water pills so I just keep putting
everything's going through
too much information Tom
okay
uh Victor's asking how Mexico City is in
the winter I want to go soon
yeah I don't imagine it probably doesn't
get cold right I mean
it's probably similar
it's dry though right I don't think it's
like I was gonna say it's similar to
Florida winter but it's not going to be
like Florida winter because Florida
winter is just
sometimes pleasant but
it's usually pretty humid I think right
now
uh according to my little
laptop here it says it's 73 degrees and
partly cloudy
which isn't terrible
but I kind of wish that it was cooler
because it's [ __ ] November for
Christ's sake
yeah make sure it's up in the mountains
though it's cool oh yeah I guess so okay
I forgot to take that into
consideration
but yeah 73 see I kind of wish it was
down like the 60s or the 50s you know
what I mean it's like November it's only
a couple weeks until Thanksgiving I wish
it would like cool off we had a couple
days where it was kind of cool like at
night
and we just had other day we had that
tropical storm [ __ ] like roll through
here
which you know that kind of cooled It
Off
but it didn't really do much of anything
other than
be really windy
Khan says no it's cold Jenny it rains
sometimes oh okay better than here then
well like I said winter here it's
mostly warm but sometimes in the morning
or sometimes in the evening it's like
Pleasant every now and then it'll get
really cold like every now and then
it'll get like below freezing but not
usually and I mean every now and then
it'll happen like in January or February
if it's gonna happen like not in
December and there have been like some
Christmases where when I was growing up
where we actually like had to turn the
AC on like on Christmas because it was
just too warm like especially like with
all the people in the house and stuff
because when where I grew up like my
grandmother's house
um she just had she didn't have central
air she just had a window unit and it
was like in the dining room so it was a
very very big deal she would always like
wait because it's expensive you know
like to run it in the summertime and you
didn't run it the rest of year so it
would always be like this big deal where
she would like wait like a really long
time like before because we would just
keep begging her it's like please turn
the air on please turn the air on it's
like it's so hot it's so hot and she
would like hold out and hold out and
hold out like growing up
um and she would hold out because she
could take it she didn't care about
being hot and we were just like please
we're dying oh my God and then finally
it would be like the end of May and
she'd be like okay we're turning the air
on everybody be like we and it'd be like
that'd be like a big deal like turning
the air on day because you knew like
when it was coming on it was staying on
like all summer because she just like
let it run continuously
and then like when you turned it off
usually you didn't turn it off until
like after Halloween so it was usually
like right about now that you would be
turning it off like in November and then
even then like sometimes everybody would
come over for Thanksgiving or everybody
would come over for Christmas and it
would get like really really warm in the
house and everybody would complain so
then she'd have to like turn it back on
but usually once she turned it off that
was it was off for the year she wasn't
[ __ ] around you know what I mean it
was just kind of like a one or the other
like proposition that's kind of what it
was
um let's see Victor says I have to go
next September 19th to Mexico City
yeah you wanted to go to Mexico City
didn't you I'd go anywhere in Mexico I'd
go to TJ I don't care
I don't care let's go cities I think is
kind of that's kind of like the big
that's a big city that's one of the
biggest cities in North America
um but I've heard that it's got It's got
too many [ __ ] Gringos there man if I
want to go I'm gonna see some Mexicans
I'd rather go to [ __ ] a place like TJ
and well yeah go hang out with [ __ ]
Cod people that I know you want to hang
out with people that live in the area
well yeah and see the real thing you
don't want to do tourist [ __ ] yeah I
never really understood people that I
don't like that well I never understood
people that would well especially I mean
like when they're like a regular dude
unless you have money falling out your
ass which most people don't
um why would you want to pay like all
this money to go to a whole other
country and then just do hang out with
foreigners and then hang out with other
people that were like that's why I never
understood like Americans that wanted to
go to like Europe or whatever and just
like do American [ __ ] like we're gonna
go to Europe and we're gonna eat at
McDonald's I'm like yeah what for you
can eat a McDonald's back home yeah I
you know I'm fluent in Portuguese I grew
up in Brazil so I can I can read and
understand Spanish well it's real close
to Portuguese if I speak Portuguese to
them they don't quite understand it I
know the basics of their language so
like a fake uh a [ __ ] Spanish
sentence it would take me a while to do
the to Tran to do the conversion between
the two it's a Latin language it's the
same root language it's just
they do things differently you know the
the the uh the articles are a little bit
different uh but there's still verb
conjugation most of the nouns are the
same
oh but they but some of it is regional
dialects too so you got to pick that up
um I noticed that the the rhythm of
Mexican Spanish is a lot faster than
Portuguese Portuguese is a lot slower
um they just kind of they they roll ours
and stuff which which I've heard of roll
ours and you don't roll any R's in uh
Portuguese it's just have a different
way of doing it but
if I was there for a few months I'd pick
it up I'd be able to speak Spanish in a
couple months
I mean I took Spanish as a kid in school
for several years like you don't really
get speaking experience no that's really
what it is it has to be conversation
like it would probably come back to me
so honestly I took French for longer I
took French for four years but so that
might come back quicker but
I'm not really sure but I hear it and I
can hear it and I understand it if I
could know most of it
reading it I understand almost all of it
by reading it it's it's real close to
Portuguese
but for some reason
um
Spanish speakers don't understand
Portuguese and I think it's because
Portuguese has so much Portuguese has a
lot of most of the same nouns that
Spanish has but Portuguese has more it
has a lot of Italian Italian
Alternatives and french-based Alternate
alternative nouns in it
um and Portuguese articles
sound more and and and and pronouns
sound more like something out of French
um
that's all picture says Portuguese and
Spanish is a one-way Street Portuguese
can understand Spanish pretty easily but
not the other way yeah and then Khan
said it's like Italian and Spanish it's
very similar honestly when I first
started because I started learning
Italian for like for a little while and
I was surprised at like how easy Italian
was like if you already had a background
in like Spanish and French like Italian
was like really really easy what's weird
though is that if you're if you if you
know Portuguese you can understand
Romanian
and evidently there's no relation
between Romanian and Portuguese but I
can hear Romanian I don't know what
they're saying
don't ask and a Brazilian told me the
same thing it's like yeah you can
understand Romanians why and if you go
on Wikipedia
and try to find the roots of the
Romanian language it supposedly is not
related to Portuguese but I don't
believe that it must be one of those
weird conversion Evolutions yeah yeah I
don't believe it I think it's it's it's
it's got to be Latin based and it's got
to be something oh yeah Victor said
Romanian is a romance language yeah it's
like Italian yeah but they say it's not
related to Portuguese but it's got to be
I am I can understand probably there's
probably a relationship yeah it's not
like it you know they're not from Mars
or anything like that
Khan says uh and as an observation if
you try to speak Spanish even if you
don't know it well you'll get more
respect because you tried and people are
more open to you I kind of feel like
that's probably true in most countries
of the world
um you know it's the same here well yeah
and I think that's kind of why some you
know there's that stereotype of like the
Ugly American who just like goes to
another country and like refuses to
speak the language just shouts English
louder tries to bring America with
everyone gets mad so yeah and the thing
about it is that I kind of feel like
well and particularly like a lot of
Europeans and stuff like that even if
English isn't their first language a lot
of them do learn English in school so a
lot of them are pretty good like can you
know speak pretty decent English so a
lot of times what they told me when I
took French in high school and this was
like a long time ago but they basically
said a lot of French people can speak
English because they speak they teach it
to them in school
um but if you just come at them and like
don't even attempt to like speak French
like when you're in France then they
will pretend that they don't speak
English which I said well I don't know
if they would all do that but I said
well you can't really blame them I would
probably do the same thing
I wouldn't pretend that I mean if you're
going to be obnoxious about it and be
like I have no idea what you're saying
even though I totally do you know what I
mean so I can I can see that I could see
that I don't know if they do that really
but that's I remember them telling me
that my glass
all right so you seem like you're
getting all antsy it's time it's eight
o'clock yeah you're dropping [ __ ] all
over the floor I'll be fine we need to
like make some stuff to eat and then I
gotta change my clothes and put some
shoes on for tonight you guys have a
good weekend yeah we'll be back on
Sunday talking about I don't know we'll
be talking about a movie but I don't
know which one yet because we haven't
watched it yet
we'll watch something tomorrow night and
uh maybe we'll talk about some more
Universal monster movies because we've
been watching those yeah we watched
Frankenstein we watched Frankenstein and
then we were starting to watch Bride of
Frankenstein but I fell asleep yeah
Brian Frankenstein was looking better
well a lot of people think brighter
Frankenstein was better than the
original Frankenstein which that's kind
of one of the movies that gets brought
up when they're like oh the sequel
that's better than the original yeah I
mean I love Frankenstein I'm not saying
that but so maybe we could do that maybe
we could do some like Universal models
okay that'd be fun all right uh all
right so hopefully you guys have a good
weekend and we'll see you guys again on
Sunday so thanks for dropping by thanks
for your super chats and everything like
that so we'll see you guys again on
Sunday evening good